عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد
ف كلامنا موصول
حول ايات سوره الرعد من كتاب
الله وقد سبق ان ذكرنا ان ترتيب هذه
السوره في المصحف غير
ترتيبها من ناحيه النزول فان هذه السوره
مكيه الا بعض ايات الا ايه او ايتين على
حسب خلاف بين العلماء في
ذلك لكن استقر كلام العلماء على ان هذه
السوره سوره مكيه انزله الله سبحانه
وتعالى قبل مهاجره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من مكه الى
المدينه
يقول سبحانه وتعالى المف لام ميم را تلك
ايات
الكتاب اي هذه الايات التي من هذه السوره
فانها ايات
الكتاب هذه الاضافه ايات
الكتاب يعني ايات من
الكتاب
وهذه
السوره افتتح افتتحها الله سبحانه وتعالى
بالحروف المقطعه الم لام مم
ر
وكل صوره من كتاب الله افتتحت بهذه الحروف
حروف الهجاء
المقطعه
فانها تشير بذلك هذه الحروف تشير الى
اعجاز كلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى والى عظيم شان
القران
والى المعاني التي في هذا الكتاب بانه لا
يمكن حتى لو اجتمعت الانس والجن على ان
ياتوا بمثل هذا
القران
نظما واختيارا للكلمات والمواضيع
وانتخاب
للقصص وهدايه للخلق واختيارا للغه وما
شابه ذلك
فانها
لا
يمكن لاحد ان ياتي بمثل هذا
القران حتى لو اجتمعت الانس والجن على ذلك
يقول الله تعالى كل ان اجتمعت الانس والجن
على ان ياتوا بمثل مثل هذا القران لا
ياتون بمثله ولو كان بعضهم لبعض
ظهيرا واذا نظرنا في لغه العرب الف لام
ميم را هذه
حروف حروف ما لها معنى في كلام
العرب
يعني اذا قلنا في لغه العرب لو نظرنا في
جميع القواميس في
جميع كتب اللغه في
جميع ما جاء عن العرب في كلامهم لم نجد
منا لهذه الحروف الهجاء
المقطعه فليس لها معنى في لغه العرب وانما
لها مغزى هي تشير لها
مغزى كانه يقول سبحانه وتعالى هذا
القران
فانه
من هذه الحروف التي
تتعاطين جميعكم ولكن لا يمكنكم ان تاتوا
بمثل هذا
القران وذلك لو قلنا مثلا
ل لو قلنا
مثلا جعلنا مسابقه مثلا
بين
غزالين او جعلنا مسابقه مثلا بين خ
شياطين فلا بد من اجل ان تكون هذه
المسابقه
تبين حقيقه هذين
المسابق وتبين لنا وتبدي لنا
ايهما اشد مهاره فلا
بد ان يكون الاداه نفس الاداه نفس القماش
نفس الامكاني
لابد ان يكون نفس
الامكانيات ويكون كل شيء متزن بين
المتسابقين فكذلك الله سبحانه وتعالى تحدى
الخلق تحدى من شك في انزال هذا
القران ان ياتي بمثل هذا القران ان ياتي
بمثله وان ياتي بعشر سور من مثله وان ياتي
بسوره واحده من
مثله
ف ذلك ان الله سبحانه وتعالى يفتتح كثيرا
من سور القران بهذه الحروف وكانه يشير الى
الامكانيات والى الاداه يقول انظروا نفس
الحروف وهي
في مستطاع جميعكم لكن لو اجتمعتم لما
استطعتم ان تاتوا بمثل هذا القران وهي
ايضا في
استطاعه محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم فانه
كذلك يتعاطى هذه الحروف هي موجوده عنده
ويحفظها
جيدا ولكنه لا يمكنه ان ياتي بمثل هذا
القران فلذلك تجد في القران ان الله
سبحانه وتعالى اذا افتتح سوره بهذه
الحروف جاء بعد هذه الحروف اشار الى
القران الم لام م ذلك الكتاب لا ريب فيه
الم لام م ر تلك ايات الكتاب كفها يا عين
ص ذكر رحمه ربك عبده زكريا وهذا فيه ذكر
ايش فيه ذكر لبعض المعاني التي لا توجد في
الكتب السابقه وانما توجد في القران فهي
خصيصه
كذلك في
سوره نون فان الله تعالى يقول نون والقلم
وما يسطرون ما ذكر القران ولكن ذكر اشرف
ما اشرف ما
يكتب بالقلم وذلك كلام الله سبحانه وتعالى
وهو داخل في عموم ذلك هذا الكلام ذكره
المحققون زمخشري
و ابن كثير وابن القيم وشيخ الاسلام وكثير
من علماء التفسير ومروي عن مجاهد رضي الله
عنه ورحمه الله تعالى مجاهد بن جبر وهو من
طلاب ابن
عباس حبر الامه ومفسرها ومترجم
القران
قران سوره
الرعد سوره
الرعد
ران the
13 chap with to the
‏order that in
صح
ران
مصح
رضي الله عنهم
قران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ران the order of
revelation is
different الله سبحانه
وتالى ال ل مم را these are letter
in letter
‏noan to look in all of
the words of the arabs all of their
poetry to look up in all the
diction me ال ممرا in the arabic
language we would not find definition
for those letters in that order
‏have no meaning in
themselves they articulate a meaning but
they are not in
themselves holding of any
meaning there a difference
between letters قران having
me and having me that articulate or
meaning that they gesture
to the meaning in themselves
‏as would find
any word in arab langage sent compr
simply random
letters
and the thing in english we to say for
instance
abc what is the meaning
abcc
‏this is very beginner stu this is
abc doesn't mean anything in itself
doesn't have a
definition articulates
meaning that this
is very
fundamental
beginner element
things ‏i
say from a to z what is the definition
of the letter a in english in that has
no definition or z on its own has no
meaning or if i say x y
z or if i say one two three these do not
have meanings in themselves they are not
words but they have meing that
articulate and that is
الله سبحانه وتالى
قران قران ال مم
را
قران
alet
‏chos exactly half the alet
and
letters because letter
the is
research look deep into the meing letter
could
me
to for
instance
letter no mean
‏what me they have no meaning is that
have no meaning in
themselves but they
articulate الله سبحانه
وتال uses the letter
that
our we able to use the letter weor
letter we able to compr words
‏letter for
us be
our to use these letters to comprise
words by these letters to use these
letters to make sentences of our own
even though that is the
case in spite of that we are not able to
produ any
work
قرر us
قررر سبحانه وتعالى ال مم را تلك ايات
الكتاب
‏these arees of the
book what is the book
the
me
قرانك الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله الله سبحانه
و الله سبحانه
وتعالى
seng موى عليه
السلام عليه السلام
all
‏their own version or iteration of the
book but the book is the one un
contradicting
contoured
continuous legation الله سبحانه
وتالى
والذي انزل اليك من ربك الحق ولكن اكثر
الناس لا يؤمنون هذه الايات تلك ايات
الكتاب اسم اشاره ايات الكتاب يعني ايات
من
الكتاب
والكتاب ما المقصود بالكتاب هل هو
القران هل هو اوسع معنى من
القران
الصحيح ان كلمه الكتاب في القران فان الله
سبحانه وتعالى يطلق هذه الكلمه ويراد بها
القران ويراد بها حكم الله
الشرعي حكم الله الشرعي اراده الله
الشرعيه لان اراده الله شرعيه
وكون الله سبحانه وتعالى
شرعا لا
يرضى لعباده الكفر قدرا قد
يريد او قد يشاء سبحانه وتعالى شيئا من
ذلك من اجل
مصالح فانه لا يكون شيئا
في الكون في خلق الله الا بامره سبحانه
وتعالى لكن لا يريد هذا
الشر
شرعا وان كان سبحانه وتعالى
يريد ذلك
قدرا هذا شيء من من قدر الله اراده الله
الكونيه بمعنى انه كائن فثم فرق بين ما هو
كائن وما
هو وما هو
مشروع فهذا
الكتاب جميع ما اوحاه الله سبحانه وتعالى
الى الرسل جميع ما اوحاه الله سبحانه
وتعالى الى
الرسل ال
التوراه من الكتاب والانجيل من
الكتاب وصحف ابراهيم وموسى من الكتاب
والزبور من
الكتاب وقول الله سبحانه
وتعالى اسكن انت وزوجك الجنه من
الكتاب هذا معنى واسع للكتاب
الكتاب اللام هنا للعهد العهد الذهني يعني
الذي كتبه الله سبحانه وتعالى على خلقه
شرعا كقوله تعالى كتاب الله
عليكم كتاب الله
عليكم
فقوله تعالى تلك ايات
الكتاب يعني هذه
الايات من
القران هي الكتاب هي اراده الله سبحانه
وتعالى الشرعيه
مصوه بحروف تفهمون وتكونون بها كلامكم الا
ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى قد اختص بنظم هذه الكلمات وانتخاب
هذه المعاني وهذه الكلمات والمواضيع
والقصص يقول تعالى والذي انزل اليك من ربك
الحق ولكن اكثر الناس لا يؤمنون الواو هنا
استئنافيه يعني جمله
جديده يعني ممكن الانسان يقراها تلك ايات
الكتاب
والذي لا
المقصود تلك ايات الكتاب
تقف والذي انزل اليك من ربك الواو هنا
استئنافيه يعني جمله
جديده والذي انزل اليك من ربك الحق جميع
ما انزل اليك من ربك سواء كان من القران
او من السنه او من الوحي او من المعجزات
او من الرؤى التي كان يراها النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
قبل النبوه وقبل حادثه غر حراء الى غير
ذلك هذا كله من ماذا كله الحق من الله
سبحانه وتعالى قوله من ربك ولم يقل من
الله لانه اضاف الربوبيه اليه يعني
الربوبيه الخاصه من عنايه الله سبحانه
وتعالى من ربك
انت ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون الناس لا يؤمنون بهذا الحق فهذا لا
يغض من صحه هذا الحق ولا ياخذ منه ولا
ينال منه ابدا
ولا
ينقصه
وانما الحق لا يحتاج الى الناس الناس هم
الذين يحتاجون الى
الحق لذلك
جاء في كلمه الحق كلمه التقوى العروه
الوثقى قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حكايه عن نوح عليه عليه
السلام ان السماوات السبع والارضين السبع
لو وضعنا في كفه ولا اله الا الله في كفه
رجحت بهن يعني لا اله الا الله رجحت بهن
يعني من جميع الخلق السماوات السابع
والاراضين السابع يعني الخلق
كله لماذا رجحت هذه الكلمه بهنا هذه
الكلمه لا تحتاج الى السماوات والارض
السماوات والارض تحتاج الى هذه الكلمه وهي
خلقت من اجل هذه الكلمه فالحق لا يحتاج
الى الى الخلق بل الخلق يحتاجون الى
الحق ولذلك الله سبحانه وتعالى من اسمائه
الحق لكن كون الناس يعرضون عن الحق هذا لا
يدل على نقصان الحق وانما يدل على نقصان
الناس نقص موجود في الناس يعرضون عن الحق
ليس لان الحق غير واضح او لانه يعرضون عن
الحق لانه غير موافق لهواهم بس ما في سبب
اخر هم يتبعون اهواءهم بغير هدى من الله
هذا هو السبب ولذلك ياتون
ب
يجادلون بالباطل ليدحضوا به الحق وقال
تعالى وكان الانسان اكثر شيء جدله يجادل
ويعلم وهو على نفسه بصيره وهو كفى به على
نفسه شهيدا لكن
يجادل يجادل ويلبس
ويغمض ويكذب
ويفجر في الخصو في الخصومه
لماذا الذي يدفع الانسان لذلك هو الهوى
والا فالحق
واضح فلذلك ليس من شروط الانبياء ان ياتوا
من
اي من ان يكونوا من صنف معين من الناس ليس
من شروط
الانبياء ان يكون النبي من
اشراف ال القريه يكون من
اي اثرياء القريه مثلا او اثرياء القوم
ليس
شرطا هم يزعمون ذلك ليس شرطا ان ياتي
النبي ولا ياكل الطعام ولا يمشي في
الاسواق ليس شرطا ان لا
يتزوج ليس شرطا ان يكون
ملكا ليس شرطا ان انبياء اذا جا جاءهم احد
من
معاند فقالوا نريد ان تفعل كذا وكذا وكذا
من الايات ليس يجب عليه ان يستجيب لذلك قل
انما الايات عند الله وانما انا نذير مبين
هذا لا ياخذ من الحق
شيئا فهذه الايات هي الحق والذي انزل الى
الله والذي انزله الله الى رسوله هو
الحق طيب اذا كان هذا الحق لماذا لم يجتمع
ويكون موضع اجماع
بين الناس بين البشر
نقول ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون لماذا اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون
لكونهم ليسوا متجردين للحق اكثر الناس ليس
متجردا للحق باحثا
عنه
نابذ ومنفق الغالي والنفيس في سبيل طلب
الحق بل اكثر الناس يفعلون ذلك في سبيل
الراحه
والدعا
والشهوه هذا هو الذي يدفع اكثر
الناس الله سه
وى
from yet most people do not
believe yet most people do not
believe what has been revealed to you
from your
lord is the truth this is
more
all
قرانه جيل عليه السلام that he has in his
sleep or even vis that he had before he
was a propet or before he was a prophet
and a messenger mons
prel
his of
the message ‏and the first veres of the
قران first encounter جبريل عليه السلام
was
prud
with si mons
of
premonition that عليه الصه واللام
when pron of things of things to
occur
and they would come to pass ‏as
عليه all this tru from lord
now notice that he says yet most people
do not
believe if a lot of people believe
something does this tell us that
is
onid no very few people this over tell
us
‏tell
us cic
unle fact that most people don't believe
that the answer is no if we were to
follow that train of
thought most of the people on earth
believe
that they believe in the trinity they
believe that jesus son
mary
الله سبحانه
وتال
مح صلى الله عليه وس people on earth
don't believe that if we to what most
people believe and do not
believe
people would our chic
‏behi most people the earth
today perhaps believe
in many things that are categorically
wrong and people belief are sed by time
and
place andate of
being this does not articulate
‏just because noes that few people
that
rather the truth isid
in the tru is that a type
people people
are ‏const search of the truth those
give all they have order to the tru will
to sacrifice for the truth those types
of
individuals it matters to us what they
believe and what they don't
believe but general masses of people
general masses of people are not sed by
truth or lack there they are not dis by
falsehood
‏general masses of people are sed by
comfor the general masses of people are
dis by
challenge anything that challenges them
in any way be the way that they think
the way that they see the
world that that turns and hinders most
people right there out
theat and so ‏the idea
that the truth should have the most
followers is not
true
tru الله سبحانه
وتالى وما اكثر الناس ولو حرصت
بالمؤمنين
not if you really really focus on them
if you really really look at them ‏you
will find that they are they fail to
believe they really do not
believe most
people الله سبحانه
وتال وط اكثر من في الارض يضلوك عن سبيل
الله
take ‏the fact when
verses propet صل الله عليه وسلم
heion in being
they were being shown hostility they
were being
repressed they were being transgress
against الله سبحانه وتالى them and he
said this is the truth from your lord
but most people don't believe most
people do not believe
الله سبحانه
وتالى
need والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اعين والحمد لله
رب ‏l